[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unix und auch
nicht nichts häufig gesprochen natürlich
immer irgendwie es alles was wir in
dieser vorlesung abdecken nicht häufig
besprochen dass die ganze idee aber okay
und noch mal übrigens in zwei wochen ist
links verdient also nicht nicht oder bei
mir aus gerne kommen habe sie wenn von
mir bestimmt nichts hören heute unser
thema des tages ist frauen in der
spätantike und zuerst soll ich
vielleicht sagen was ich unter
spätantike verstehe eigentlich verstehe
ich spät unter spätantike die zeit
mindestens des römischen reiches
im gegensatz zur republik aber
normalerweise verwendet man dieses wort
spätantike für vielleicht zweite oder
dritte jahrhundert nach christus bis
zerfall des römischen reiches oder
besser gesagt bis der fall des
westlichen wir müssen gleich ist weil
die östliche hälfte nicht verfahren zu
fangen ist das viel später das werden
wir auch besprechen
später in der serie in diesem fall werde
ich eigentlich
palionis tische die hessische zeit
sowohl wie die spätantike abdecken und
das heißt weil wir letzte woche mit
aristoteles schluss gemacht haben
alles was nach alles dort ließ kommt und
dann bis ende der antike also es geht
hier darum hat träume und figuren so
schlagen die zwischen alles dort ließ
und mittelalter gelebt haben also sehr
viel zeit
kurzum was 1000 jahre
die texte die wir besprechen müssen sind
vorwiegend auf griechisch dass man nicht
vergessen dass alt ist immer noch die
typische sprache war für viele autoren
selbst unter den römern weil in der
östlichen hälfte des römischen reiches
deswegen also wenn man bis ans denkt die
restliche hälfte soll man nicht denken
die haben leute auf latein geschrieben
bis die kaiser nicht nicht mehr daran
und dann ist es anfangs umgestellt
wieder auf griechische nein natürlich
nicht sie haben einfach die ganze zeit
auf altgriechisch geschrieben aber im
westen haben sie in seit der c zero
cicero und server ist er sehr bestimmend
in dieser hinsicht
er hat er war eigentlich der erste der
dann philosophische texte auf latein
verfasst hat oder unter den ersten die
texte die wir besprechen werden sind in
der tat auf in der lateinischen sprache
einschließlich augustinus der sicherlich
keine frau war aber doch eine rolle
heute spielen wird wegen seiner mutter
monica
das ist schon ein hinweis auf ein thema
was uns heute beschäftigen wird nämlich
mehrere von den figuren die in dieser
späteren antiken zeit ausharren
diesen familienmitglieder von berühmten
philosophen oder theologen zum beispiel
monika oder marina die schwester von
golfern itzá und basel von kaiser er
zwei hauptfiguren der spätantiken
philosophie unter frauen sozusagen also
sehr viel zeit und wird das und die also
zeit haben für heute ist herrlich die
hellenistische zeit das von alexander
größe grob des
zerfall des der römischen republik
wie ging es frauen in dieser zeit
gleiche antwort wie immer sehr
unterschiedlich aber wohl wegen schlecht
allerdings waren die möglichkeiten für
philosophinnen in der späteren sei vor
allem der spätantike nicht in der helms
zeit aber in der später die waren besser
als in der klassischen antike also wenn
man rom im dritten jahrhundert nach
christus mit athen im fünften oder
vierten jahrhundert vor christus
vergleich geht es für frauen viel besser
nicht nur philosophisch sondern haben
frauen mehr rechte von demokratisch
tragen sie können eigenen besitz haben
und sie haben oft eine rolle in der an
der politischen macht genießen können
das ist also wenn sie ein bisschen über
römische geschichte wissen dann wissen
sie wahrscheinlich dass mehrere frauen
auftauchen die dafür berüchtigt waren
weil sie so viel interesse an macht
hatten und auch weil sie oft angeblich
sexuell völlig unkontrolliert waren zum
beispiel agrippina die die eine
beziehung mit mehreren kaisern gehabt
hat aber die schwester von von dem ganz
schlimmen war und auf jeden fall die
diese frauen sind natürlich eine große
ausnahme also wird wir reden hier von
gleichen frauen und man sieht vielleicht
sogar dass die männliche art die darüber
schreiben
nervös sind weil diese frauen irgendwie
an macht kommen wo die männer das ein
bisschen unangenehm finden und die ganze
idee dass frauen dann
wirklich die apolitische das politische
geschehen zum teil bestimmen können
das ist für diese männliche atom sehr
sehr unangenehm und deswegen beschreiben
sie immer als diese hinterlistige
sechsmal unkontrollierte gestalten
beschreiben
caligula irgendwie wissen sie wenn ihr
sowas könig oder heißt ist nicht sein
rechter name steuerdaten stiefelchen
genau das war sein spitzname als kind
als sie als er mit dem armee unterwegs
war so süß oder und dann mit ihrer hilfe
ok also dass also thema frauen in der
spätantike im allgemeinen sehr
interessant und man könnte sicherlich
vorlesungen in der geschichte fakultäts
geben überall wo man das mit der
früheren seit vergleich das werde ich
natürlich nicht machen aber es wichtig
zu wissen dass frauen ein bisschen
unabhängiger waren es in der heimischen
kultur mit der mit im anfang des
christentums kommt wieder was anderes
vor allem bietet christentum eine
möglichkeit für frauen aus dieser ganzen
familienleben geschichte auszusteigen
praktisch durch pass käse und dadurch
dass sie sagen können also kinder
kriegen und familie bezeugen dass es
nichts das beste was eine frau machen
kann
das beste was eine frau machen kann ist
genau das was einmal machen kann nämlich
boys sein fromm sein und unabhängig
leben also diese es geht also nicht
müsst glas zu sein aber es geht wirklich
sehr viel um sex hier weil wir mit
christentum
kann man so sagen aus moralischen
gründen sich weigern zu haben und das
ist nicht nur nicht verachtet sondern
wird sogar gelobt und das ist neu in
deinen ticken kultur also sagen ich habe
keinen ehemann weil ich so jugendlich
band oder ich habe einen ehemann
aber wir haben jetzt seit 40 jahren
nicht zusammen geschlafen weil wir beide
so kündigt sind es gibt geschichten über
diese christliche frauen die die männer
dazu überreden oder mindestens einreden
dass sie nichts zusammen schlafen sollen
wegen also zwecks typen und ja so kalte
dusche und gott starts familie leben
praktisch und das ist das kommt immer
wieder als thema in der in den
geschichten über diese frauen also
kurzum kann man sagen dass man mit
christentum eine gelegenheit hat oder
eine möglichkeit für frauen ein
intellektuelles leben zu führen oder
mindestens ein spirituelles leben zu
führen
im gegensatz zu den erwartungen die
vorher geherrscht haben
und wie gesagt sie würden sogar dafür
gelobt wir haben biograf biografische
werke über diese frauen und das sind
eigentlich hab sogar geografische texte
wo die daten dieser frauen beschrieben
wird manchmal sogar die wunder und dass
das spielt immer eine rolle dass die
frau entweder nichts geheiratet hat oder
mit dem mann gelebt hat aber nicht als
frage nicht als eva man könnte
vielleicht sogar sagen sie haben die
gelegenheit gegen christentum haben sie
die möglichkeit wie männer so leben zum
ersten mal und das wir werden wir werden
sehen dass es eine große rolle spielt im
leben mehreren philosophinnen die wir
besprechen
okay ein paar beispiele dafür
melanie die um für unter 10 nach
christus gestorben ist sie war eine sehr
reiche frau die etwas ausnahmsweise in
diesem geschützten ihr ganzes vermögen
nichts werk geschenkt hat weil es war
typisch typische biografie aus der
spätantike hat dem gleichen muster
reiche person normalerweise ein mann
aber meine frau super superreich
versteht plötzlich dass jesus christus
gott ist nimmt ihn als beispiel denkt ja
armut ist die richtige lösung für mich
verschenkt alle seinen seinem geld und
besitz an die armen und lebt asketisch
mit da nichts das ist typisch aber bei
melania ist ist nicht der fall
sie hat geld neben 170 war sehr
großzügig aber sie hat mit ihrem geld
dann die möglichkeit angeboten für
andere frauen zusammen zu leben und hat
seine story aufgebaut für diese fragen
und es gibt ein leben der maler melanie
natürlich von einem mann geschrieben wo
jede mehrere also jede fähigkeit
beschrieben wird und die wunder dieser
gequert hat usw
ein anderes beispiel das team kritiker
also ganz typisch sehr englisch zu
texten wie das leben von als antenne der
große deutsch auf englisch
die gleiche geschichte und viele leute
haben dann natürlich inspiration an
diesen gestalten empfunden haben diese
texte gelesen und diese leute aus vor
wende genommen
ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen dass all
diese figuren vergorenen philosophen
sind mindestens nichts unseren szene
also die haben zum beispiel keine
philosophische texte verfasst und keine
argumente verfasst
allerdings konnte man damals solche
leute als philosoph beschreiben für das
office oder lust auf was auch psychisch
das geht zurück zu was das ich schon
gesagt habe nämlich das in der antike
philosophie software tugendhafte mensch
ist muss nicht heißen alles dort ließ
wir interessieren uns nicht aber
natürlich schon für philosophen oder
philosophinnen also dass das war
praktisch nur umso eher klein warum
diese möglichkeit offen war also
sozusagen als ein schritt in richtung
philosophinnen so haben ist das klar
irgendwas tun dürfen außer einfach
kinderkriegen haushalts dann führen
ich habe ein zitat auf dem herd was ich
sehr schön finster
er fragte die swiss auf englisch das
können sie auch lesen dass über es hat
sich ein paar gleich ins deutsche die
tat sei die tatsache dass diese frauen
so gelebt haben wie auch männliche
mönche hatten die freiheit geboten
aktivitäten durchführen die nichts
völlig angemessen werden für weltlichen
christlichen mutter oder hausfrauen
vertriebsaktivitäten die für diese
ästhetische wenn der mensch
dass es kritische fragen nicht nur
gestattet worden sondern sogar empfohlen
war würden von den kirchenvätern oder
die weiß nicht was sie unter chapman
versteht aber kirchliche autorität was
du sagen
dahinter ok so dass so viel zu frauen im
allgemeinen
was ist mit philosophinnen erstens kann
man sagen dass das habe ich schon
eigentlich schon mehrmals gesagt mit der
ausnahme der erste täter fast all diese
philosophische schulen schulen die wir
sehr starken mit tennis muss im
spätantiken verbinden waren offen für
frauen
also wir haben die chemiker die story
vielleicht nicht die skeptiker aber die
sind die zyniker die zürcher die korean
air und die platonische wir wissen dass
all diese traditionen offen waren für
frauen was heißt hier offen
das heißt zum beispiel dass die
vorlesungen dass die philosophen
vorlesungen geboten haben oder
vielleicht seminare lesergruppen dass
ein bisschen schwerer weißer stangen
genau was los war und das war bestimmt
als sehr verschieden von zeit zu zeit
die all diese sitzungen waren für frauen
offen zum beispiel putin im dritten
jahrhundert nach christus
er ist der begründer der sogenannten
neue platten ismus er hätte diesen
ausdruck nie verwendet ist der astag
würde in dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
erfunden aber er war platt honecker also
er hat sich selbst als platonischer
gesehen und er hat eine schule
einschließlich hat natürlich wann die
schule hauptsächlich männer
einschließlich previews der
herausgeberteam ist es werke und auch
ein autor von mehreren
eigenen werken einschließlich ein brief
an seine frau keller die ich beim
beschreiben werde gut auf jeden fall in
diese in diesen kreis des platins waren
frauen anwesend also aus förder
sozusagen also uns die unter den zehn
ihr können und vielleicht den karrieren
aber vor allem bei den scenic zynikern
und historiker haben wir damit zu tun
dass wir philosophische schulen haben
die die werte der damaligen gesellschaft
wirklich kritisiert haben um in ein teil
dieser kritik war eben frauen was als
gleichgültig zu behandeln
und das können wir sehr schön an das
beispiel von hier sehen und das werde
ich auch bald besprechen also kurzum
gibt es viele möglichkeiten in der
späteren antiker sind der harrisons
seiten der rechten spätantike wo frauen
dann philosophisch tätig sein könnten
vielleicht ist das nicht ganz im
gegensatz zu dem was wir in der
klassischen antike finden weil da muss
man daran denken was waren die beste
beispiele die wir damals hatten für
vieles offen
frauen bei den kategorien und das ist
irgendwie ende ist ein geschlossener
kreis haben ihre eigene regeln das ist
sozusagen eine gesellschaft für sich und
die definieren sich gegen die werte der
kultur also hat dieses kreises und das
haben wir auch bei den historikern von
sinken aber mal 100 also wirklich sehr
sehr stark sehr konter kulturell so
sagen
wie konnte kurzweil werden sie bald
hören und es wird lustig hoffentlich die
all diese weibliche mitglieder denen
werde ich dann gleich besprechen
zuerst wollte ich nur ein bisschen über
werke von die die von männern gefasst
würden wo frauen als thema auftauchen
genau wie wir bei plattform des sockels
gemacht haben werde ich nicht sehr lang
machen aber es trotzdem interessant also
ein thema das uns bisher etwas verfolgt
hat leute dieses thema ökonomik also
haushalts lehre und in der spätantike
haben sie immer noch diese idee man hat
ehefrau emma der ehemannes der chef
die ehefrau hat bestimmte aufgaben
innerhalb der familie oder innerhalb den
haushalt und in der spätantike gegensatz
zur früheren antike haben wir werke die
noch erhalten sind die ausdrücklich
diese dieses thema sozusagen
wissenschaftlich thematisieren oder
behandeln
das beste beispiel heißt über der des
haushalts oder über haushalts verwaltung
vielleicht von einem gewissen kreisen
von dem eigentlich doch nichts wissen es
angeblich ein neue peter er das
vielleicht nichts und bedeutendes weil
wir gesehen haben da die wichtig
haushalt werde in der katholischen
tradition war aber seine angeblich
pythagoras ansichten kommen mich sehr
stark in dieser chef durch in diesem
werk beschreibt preißn die verschiedene
teile des haushalts also was der ehemann
zu tun hat der haushalte was die frau zu
tun hat was die meinen guten kinder gut
erziehen kann was die sklaven machen
müssen wie man die sklaven behandeln
soll
und was auch an den berg den berg es
daran interessant ist nicht für uns aber
im allgemeinen ist dass er relativ viel
über geld sprechen
sind sie das halt wenn man daran denkt
wie wenig antiker philosophen und oder
hausen dafür die philosophen wie wenig
sie sich über geld äußern in einer weise
die wirklich interessant erst die sagen
nur geldmacherei schlecht also manchmal
geld nicht zu hoch bewerten aber weißen
bescheid wirklich wie man das gestalten
soll damit dass das haus finanziell
erfolgreicher wird und die ehefrau
spielt hier eine rolle
sie ist wie so oft die partnerin des
ehemannes und muss ihre aufgaben dann
erfüllen damit das haushalt dann
erfolgreich wird finanziell erfolgreich
selbst an den beispiel sieht man dass
die die ehefrau hier nicht so
beschrieben ist als ob sie dann ihre
eigene erfüllung suchen soll sie es
wirklich nur da um zu schauen dass das
haushalt erfolgreich ist das ein
bisschen im gegensatz zum e man wo man
den eindruck hat er will irgendwie er
ist als individuum wichtig in einer art
und weise wie die ehefrau nichts ist
allerdings hat der mann auch seine rolle
innerhalb des haushaltes also vielleicht
ist preis einsicht dass haushalt so
richtig sein
und das egal was die individuellen
menschen dann machen was schon neu bei
preußen ist ist dass er die emotionale
verbindung zwischen so zwischen dem
ehepaar dann betont also er gibt
praktisch zu dass der mann und die frau
verliebt sein soll und das ist besser
laufen wird wenn sie sich gern haltung
radikal und ich habe gelesen in einem
buch darüber
das ist praktisch eine vorahnung von
christentum das liebe vielleicht
manchmal eine rolle innerhalb der
familie spielt natürlich nicht liebe von
mutter verkennt oder von vater verdient
das war immer da aber zwischen dem
ehepaar das ist nicht neu
zb in diesen briefen von die angebliche
briefen der kategorie anderen kategorien
das wird nie thematisiert also sie muss
man versuchen ihn zu bleiben und so
weiter
aber liebe kommt eigentlich vor aniston
den hingehen briefen okay das ist
interessant dann haben wir die
historiker die genau wie platon an vor
allem ganz am anfang mit zenon von kitty
um übrigens gefahr
wie sehen es gibt zwei mal 10
es gibt szenen von lr der schüler von
paradies dann gibt es szenen von kitty
um der begründer des staates muss also
aufpassen es gibt auch viele die
organistion diagnose und einer kommt
dann bald und der spätantike geheißen
alle harmonie muss viele viele harmonie
das ist ganz schlimm aber nichts durch
schlemmen wie in der arabischen
tradition welche immer und mohammed
meinen sie
der begründer des tourismus hat auch
einen text namens polit er geschrieben
dieser weg ist nicht erhalten aber wir
kennen ihn durch zitaten als andere
ratten und das war wie bei platon eine
relativ radikale
umdenken der gesellschaft
und genau wie platon hat er radikale
ideen über frauen dann vorgeschlagen und
viele sehen hier und in deutsch muss im
allgemeinen tendenz jugend und
gleichrangige reichwein gegend frauen
zuzuschreiben die für männer bestes das
beste beispiel hahn ist muss eines rufes
weil er ein gewerk schieben hat darüber
dass frauen auf philosophieren sollen
früher schon geahnt es einer von den
ersten stock ein werk namens dass frauen
die gleiche tugend besitzen wie männer
leider verloren aber haben die ideen von
muss sony es kennen wir relativ gut und
dem römischen reich also erst viel
später aus zehn und klärend ist und hier
aber wie gesagt sagte ausdrücklich ja
frauen sollen auf philosophieren
die können auch die tuben besetzen und
klassisch tourismus die die lehre erst
um die toten zu erlangen muss man
philosophieren deswegen müssen frauen
auch philosophieren wie es gibt einen
ganzen artikel über darüber übrigens von
nußbaum ist auf dem herrn dort ganz
unten
und sie ist sie etwas zweifelhaft dass
es wirklich so toll ist wie es klingt
weil wir zum beispiel passagen in sonys
finden wo er sagen sachen sagt wie
fragen sollen tugendhaft sein und ein
argument dafür
sie wird so effektive im haushalt seien
weil sie tugendhaft ist also weder der
seite aber ist als also ich würde ich
sagen es passt auch sehr gut zu den
süßen leere
frauen als potenziell tugendhaft und als
potenzielle philosophinnen so zu
beschreiben denn die historische
anthropologie sozusagen also die theorie
des menschen bei service muss er ist
folgendes sie lernen dass jeder mensch
durch und durch vernünftig ist
das heißt dass im gegensatz zu der
platonischen zählen ehre haben wir keine
drei sälen teil oder zählen also nichts
mit vernunft mut und begierde nur
vernunft wenn jemand sich entscheidet
zum beispiel körperliche lust zu
genießen stadt thun nach zu leben was
wir alle tun bleibt ins torkeln weil
keiner von uns wirklich ein philosoph es
oder wirklich weise ist was wir da
machen ist eine falsche meinung oder
einer raschen meinen zu folgen
also ich entwickle die meinung oder den
eindruck kuchen es lecker kuchen es auch
lecker aber dahin dass beschreiten wir
nichts freue mich in deutschland
deutscher kuchen amerikanische kuchen
deswegen bin ich hier und da aber
hauptsächlich zwecks guten ok hat und
dann habe ich die meinung ich soll
diesen kuchen lassen
falsche meinung und dann aber das ist
sozusagen das wird alles von meiner
vernunft ausgeführt ich brauche keine
keinen anderen keine andere seele oder
zen teil meine vernunft formt eine
falsche meinung und das gilt für alle
menschen im gegensatz zu tieren nicht im
gegensatz zu frauen frauen sind auch
menschen menschen sind sind als durch
und durch vernünftig definiert werden
durch einen vernünftigen definiert also
theoretisch mindestens müssten frauen
die die möglichkeit und die fähigkeit
haben die tu wien zu erreichen und dass
das geben die historiker sahen zu man
muss ein bisschen vorsichtig sein ich
meinen zum beispiel neugeborene kinder
sind auch menschen sind aber noch nicht
fähig die tugenden zu erreichen und im
allgemeinen würden sie zugeben dass die
tu dass die potenzielle touren mit
vollkommene vernünftigkeit zusammenkommt
und dass das erst nach der kindheit dann
auftaucht dortmund deswegen könnte man
fürchten dass sie was ähnliches über
frauen sagen würden also dass frauen
viel eis wie unentwickelte menschen sind
wie kinder
aber das sagen sie nicht das hätten sie
gesagt sagen können aber gottseidank
zeichnet ihr das nicht nein
frauen sind auch sozusagen im spiel wenn
es um viel geld
also das ist schön auch die platonische
obwohl sie nicht diese sozusagen hyper
internationalistische zellen ehre haben
sie haben einen anderen grund eine rolle
oder eine mögliche rolle für fragen der
philosophie zuzugeben nämlich platon
plattform in der politik sagt laut
unklar
franken auch mitwirken als führer der
stadt und aus philosophie und das wird
aufgenommen dass es vielleicht eine
erklärung oder mit erklärung warum putin
frauen in seiner in seinem kreis hatte
das könnte auch einfach sein das ist
sozusagen einfach geld war dass solche
hoch gehobene kreise in rom
und übrigens ein kreis war in rom aber
ja er ist aus ägypten und schreibtisch
aber seine schule war dann in rom
und es kann sein dass es einfach im
dritten jahrhundert im raum einfach
normal war dass solche kreise dann
frauen auch dabei hatten aber dass
mindestens nicht und relevanz das
plateau diese sachen in der polit er
gesagt hat leider äußert sich nicht dazu
dafür müssen wir auf plus warten proctor
es ist dann ein paar generationen später
und ist unter den letzten platonischer
nun er schrieb einen kommentar über die
polit er kommentar ist vielleicht zu
viel das ist mehr wie mehrere fragen die
man sich fragen die man sich stellen
könnte über den text der polit er also
mehrere probleme die auftauchen und ein
problem ist so sagen was ist mit den
frauen
also das hat er als problematisch
gesehen oder mindestens aus
erklärung des bedürfnis bei dieser
stelle gesehen und das unter anderem
weil das mit anderen texten aus platin
vergleichs nicht unbedingt die texte die
ich gesprochen habe sondern eher die
gäste der letzte werk von platon was
niemand heute liest und dort ist die
rolle der frauen in der perfekten start
fiel beschränkter und deswegen hat
fraglos hier eine ein problem was bienen
viel mehr stört aus die frage wie geht
es frauen in unserer gesellschaft dass
er wahrscheinlich nicht so interessant
was was ihm bedeutend ist ist ich will
unbedingt vermeiden dass klatten seine
meinung verändert hat oder es sich
widerlegt hat also die frage ist wie
keiner diese zwei texte dann irgendwie
in einklang bringen
seine antwort die polit er wo frauen
mitwirken dürfen das ist eine
beschreibung der des idealen der idealen
situation also wenn alles so sagen
perfekt abläuft könnten frauen so
agieren aber merkt im leben natürlich
nicht und im echten leben haben wir eine
situation wo frauen die untertanen sind
und das beschreibt er in den neckar ist
also sozusagen realpolitik lag ist ideal
politik in der politik und von daher
könnte das kann man natürlich positiv
oder negativ bewerten also positiv
könnte man sagen ja also ergibt zu
idealerweise denn frauen nicht gleich
weil wir haben gesehen in der polit er
ist das nicht der fall habe ich sind
erlaubt die wären erlaubt die politische
man die playoffs zu kommen und zu lösen
führen
es ist dass das so sagen die gute
nachricht die schlechte nachricht ist
aber realistisch geht das nicht laut
focus
ein weiteres beispiel der frau innerhalb
oder unter den platten ickern ist wie
gesagt dieser brief von profi rios an
seine frau keller und das ist natürlich
kein werk einer frau sondern das ist
einer frau gewidmet
allerdings ist das vielleicht
interessant als text für uns weil er so
sagen
implizit seine ansichten über x mal
kellers fähigkeit zu philosophieren
bespricht und hals im allgemeinen seinen
fein verhältnis mit er bescheid
also das werde ich dann etwas erläutern
in dem brief geht es zuerst darum dass
erst sah das also anscheinend war der
anlass des briefes dass er weg war auf
urlaub besseres und er will sozusagen
aufmuntern dass sie nicht so sehr
vermisst
wir sind ganz nett und das sagt er das
kann übrigens das ist ganz typisch also
das ist so genannte thema des
konstellation philosoph ist also die das
ein versuch philosophie zu benutzen um
jemanden gesundheit
austern und da sagt direkt
philosophische sachen wie zum beispiel
das ihn vermisst ist natürlich irgendwie
aber sie muss nie vergessen dass die
dass die sachen die ganz wertvoll sind
sind nicht hier auf der erde so sind
sondern die geistige objekte und formen
die platonischer so schätzen und dass
man nie die möglichkeit davon abhängig
machen soll was in dem körperlichen
leben vorkommt weil wenn man das tut
dann kommt immer was was man mit wo dort
man unglücklich wird und vor allem geht
es darum dass makler seine frau jede
partie keiner kennt keine kontrolle
geben soll partie ist schwer zu
übersetzen aber manchmal aktionen also
die die gefühle vielleicht tief in der
unteren seele zu hause sind zum beispiel
wusste oder auch ärger oder andere
solche manchmal wird das als emotionen
übersetzt aber das ist wahrscheinlich zu
eng ist alles was man empfindet was von
seite der niedrigen seele kommt denn das
sagt ja immer wieder in dem brief dass
das ziel des lebens für uns also für uns
philosophen saison also auch firma
keller
das ziel des lebens ist wissen seit zu
erwerben und nicht diese partie zu
folgen
das schon sehr interessant sein da ist
eine beziehung mit ihr ist sowieso
interessant erklärt am anfang also man
kann von dem brief entnehmen dass sie
beide relativ alt sind
die situation ist anscheinend dass man
kellers ehemann gestorben ist und das
war ein freund von portfolios und
natürlich waren allein stehende frau
in der antike sehr nach beteiligt
deswegen sozusagen als gefallen an
seinen alten freund hat er seine frau
geheiratet
jetzt sagt fast dass sie dass er keine
interesse an sie als frau hat oder mehr
als fast er sagt das ist vielleicht die
interessanteste stelle in dem brief für
uns er sagt mach dir keine gedanken
darüber
oder macht ja kein ding also dass das
griechisches polo pony mona also das
heißt mach kein großes ding daraus ob du
weiblich bist oder männlich betrachte
dich nicht als frau denn ich hab sie ich
habe dich nicht so gesehen
das heißt als ich geheiratet habe das
als alles was weiblich ist in deiner
seele fliehen als ob du den körper eines
mannes hättest sollen sie hören wir das
auf griechischen ote und arenanet elia
sommertag monika ideen hat cisco oder
das heißt so etwas wie das was ich
gerade gesagt habe es ist wirklich
interessant als ich betrachte mich nicht
als frau also betrachte dich selbst
sieht aus frau und alles vermeiden was
in dir weiblich ist als ob du ein mensch
mensch hat dazu einen mann fest also ist
wirklich sehr interessant und man sieht
hier das genau wie die historiker die
platonische sozusagen einen grund haben
frauen philosophisch ernst zu nehmen und
der grund ist so was wie folgendes was
bin ich als aus sicht eines platonischer
was bin ich ich bin meine unsterbliche
materielle und körperliche seele frauen
habe auch haben auch sehr hier der
übrigens auch und man könnte also das
ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
aber man könnte fast sagen diese ansicht
hat kein geschlecht also du hast immer
wenn du eine frau bist hast du pech dass
du im moment in dem körper einer frau
bist aber das ist wirklich interessant
was er sagt tue als ob du den körper
eines mannes hättest also man könnte
davon fast entnehmen
deine serie konnte konnte auch genauso
gut in so einem körper sein und dann
wärst du einmal
und auch wenn man betrachtet an was man
mit dieser menschlichen seele macht
dieser unsterblichen körperlichen seele
macht was macht man da wird man denkt
also leute in platini kann das hat
überhaupt nichts mit fähigkeiten oder
aktivitäten zu tun die durch den körper
ausgeübt werden also zum beispiel
sechs seen wahrnehmung allgemein das hat
alles mit dem und mit der unteren seele
zu tun
laut dieser neue ton ickern und deswegen
könnte man wirklich sehen wir haben hier
einen sehr guten grund zu denken dass
frauen in sofern sie philosophieren
konnten also wenn eine frau wirklich
philosophisch lebt dann ist sie so gut
wie ein mann
oder anders gesagt denn ein mann oder
eine frau
das macht sind sie so gut wie kein
geschlecht mehr
natürlich drückt er das auch aus und das
würden sie immer ausdrücken als pop zu
sagen der beste zustand ist die seele
eines mannes zu haben weil sozusagen was
sie als idealfall sehen aber wenn man
durch denkt wie was die täter findet
auch die theorie wirklich kompliziert
dass das würde eigentlich heißen dass
seelen geschlechtslos sind das klingt
alles sehr gut was nicht so gut ist dass
wir sehr oft damit verbunden die
ansichten findet dass frauen sehr von
dem körper und also sehr großen einfluss
seit von seite des körpers entwenden
also für frauen ist vielleicht viel
schwieriger diese vernünftig fern und
seele wirklich einzusetzen weil sie ist
falls als ob sie ständig unter kontrolle
dieser partie sind und deswegen können
sie nicht so gut denken wie meine
natürlich 99,9 prozent der männer sind
auch in diesem zustand
es ist nur die philosophen aber es ist
mindestens ein tick schwieriger für
frauen das zu erreichen als für männer
aber das ist nicht wahr ich würde sagen
das ist nicht wahr diese saison von haus
aus männlich oder weiblich ist sondern
die zelle ist die seele die platonische
sei es nur eine unglaublich
vielleicht geschleppt bloßes geschlecht
größe substanz und das problem was die
frauen haben ist nicht dass die zelle
irgendwie kaputt ist oder wer gut
funktioniert das problem was frauen
haben denn sie ein problem haben ist
dass sie körper haben die zugang auf die
aktivitäten dieser serie verhindern
das ist das problem und die die das
gleiche problem kommt bei kindern vor
und vor allem bei tiere also wenn man
zugibt dass eine seele von einem tier
körper in ein mensch körper wandern kann
was plattform auch sagt in manchen
dialogen anscheinend also warum können
kann meine katze nicht philosophieren
könnte man sich fragen antwort
vielleicht muss ein platonischer sagen
die antwort ist nicht weil sie so sang
von haus aus psychologisch dazu unfähig
ist ihr problem ist dass ihr körper sie
so stört und daran hindert dass sie
nicht philosophieren kann
manche würden wahrscheinlich überhaupt
mache ich viele katzenbesitzer denken
wahrscheinlich des ganzen dorf
philosophien können aber ich bin
ziemlich zuversichtlich dass wenn meine
katze gute philosophische ideen hätte
sie würde das nicht mit mir teilen
okay so soviel zu platin ismus in der
antike vielleicht noch interessanter
weil wir hier wirklich
dann wollte ich wollte sagen dass das
auch dann dass wir das auch in
christentum felsen oder mindestens
ähnlich ideen die christen übernehmen
viele für solche ansichten aus den
heimischen traditionen vor allem aus
tourismus und platin ismus die
platonische lehrsälen er passt natürlich
sehr sehr gut zu christentum
denn man sofort sehen kann war wie es
sein kann dass unsere zellen dann
überleben werden damit wir alle gerettet
sein werden können
sie haben schon das problem wie wir
später sehen werden und dass da es laut
christentum dass wir später ein körper
zurück bekommen sollen wieder
wiederauferstehung oder wie das heißt
auferstehung kommt also bei der
herstellung werden wir alle wieder einen
körper bekommen und ein platonischer
würde wahrscheinlich sagen wieso also
klingt wie ein schritt in die falsche
richtung viel besser werde von den
körper für immer befreit zu werden und
deswegen müssen die christliche so offen
dass begründen und erklären warum gott
uns wie der körper geben würde
also das ist ein problem die christen
wollen und normalerweise auch behaupten
dass dies eben nicht existiert hat bevor
es in diesem körper werden die
platonisch
und gerade uns selbst sehr oft sagt dass
die seele schon existiert hat bevor es
bevor sie hier war bevor sie in den
kompletten zustand dar
also es gibt es schon probleme aber die
grundlegende metaphysische annahme die
oder annahmen die die platonischer
machen über die natur der serie passt
super gut zu christentum und deswegen
ist es nicht sehr überraschend dass
diese ansichten die wir zum beispiel bei
piräus finden dann auch bei den christen
vorkommen
übrigens zwar genau in diesen
asketischen werken wollen biographien
die vorher beschrieben habe zum beispiel
in dem leben der malaria ihr habt schon
mal genannt sie war diejenige die so
reich war und die diese kleine
gesellschaft für fromme frauen aufgebaut
hat in diesem text wird sie gelobt für
ihre männliche taten also ähnlich also
die idee ist marke frauen durch
frömmigkeit und tugend sind so perfekt
geworden dass sie praktisch wie männer
war und das ist hier wirklich zu sagen
das größte lob das man geben kann eine
eine antike frauen allerdings vielleicht
auch das eigentlich auch in die gleiche
richtung oft beschreiben sie die die
schwierigkeiten die man als asketischer
mensch empfindet weil natürlich mein
mann muss sich vorstellen was diese
leute gemacht haben dies die sind in der
antike also ohne handy oder sowas sind
sie in die würste marschiert ohne essen
haben sich in eine höhle gesessen und
dann gibt gebeten und das war es und
sind haben angeblich durch wunder monate
lang ohne essen und wasser überlebt und
und und
es gibt natürlich auch simon stellt es
der auf einer säule gelebt hat oder sich
beklagt hat dass so viele leute gekommen
sind um in beraten zu lassen deswegen
hat er die sonne höher machen lassen
damit er in sie nicht hören konnte und
so weiter also wenn ich sage es käse
dass meine sehr sehr ernst
nun mache ich mal waren dass frauen die
das gemacht haben und dass das ist
interessant weil das ist wirklich sehr
oft also sehr männlich wird es
beschrieben als eine art kampf gegen
dämonen die dann immer auftauchen um den
huskies zu verführen
und das kommt in diesem leben der
malaria vor dass sie ständig von satan
verführt werden könnte und sie muss ihn
wirklich claudia tores besiegen
das ist alles sehr sozusagen männlich
beschämt von dem autor hier ist soll man
auch nicht vergessen was sie über die
andere seite der platonischen zellen
sängerin nämlich ihr habt gesagt ja im
grunde genommen sind wir eine von uns
jeder von uns ist eine vernunft seele
aber haben diese andere aspekte oder
teile der seele
diese untere teile und das ist natürlich
genau das was uns verfährt man könnte
vielleicht sogar sagen dass man das sind
keine philosophische texte eigentlich
aber in den texten über ein von der
größe oder anderen asketen wenn wenn es
immer das wird immer dargestellt als ob
sata satan oder einen dreimann wirklich
auftakt und sagte komm zurück zur
großstadt wohl durch sex haben könntest
ist nur ein bisschen mehr
und dann musste der heilige es geht sagt
nein nein ich werde mit zu mir nehmen
usw aber haben wenn wenn man sozusagen
ein bisschen
hinter die kulissen schaut und es gibt
texte die die das ein bisschen
philosophische dann ausdrucken
man sieht dass diese dämonen sind
wahrscheinlich eine beschreibung der für
fördern die von der unteren seite kommt
es sind die begierden
dieser soll versuchen die fanszene
abzulenken weg von gott zu reißen und in
richtung den körper zu lenken und
deswegen könnte man sagen in heimischen
und auch im christlichen kreationismus
was ist denn eigentlich 22 arten
pazifismus könnte man sagen es gibt
immer diese serie gegen körper
geschichte
das ist ein kampf wo die erste serie die
fernziele versucht die interesse und den
körper zu besiegen
und deswegen haben diese leute so
radikal gegen die liste und sogar die
bedürfnisse des körpers agiert sie haben
sich gequält um den körper zu schwächen
ein gutes beispiel hier ist wieder
profis er hat ein werk verfasst wo er
erklärt warum ein guter für das oft kein
fleisch essen soll als ein hauptgrund
jetzt schon dass es unrecht den tieren
gegenüber ist also spitzt sich sehr für
vegetarismus aus mehr oder weniger aus
den gründen die wir dann irgendwie auch
benutzen wenn wir als vegetarier leben
heute aber er sagt eigentlich dass der
hauptgrund der geteilte leben ist das
fleisch so gut schmeckt
wieso ja weil wenn man zu viel lust an
ersten empfindet das erst wie er sagt
wie ein nagel eine nadel die die seele
fest an den körper sendet also wenn man
sozusagen selbst in diesem leben befreit
von den körper leben von dem körper
leben will
muss man ja so wenig lust empfinden wie
möglich und vielleicht schmeckt so gut
dass das den körper die seele ablenkt
bei den christen ist es ähnlich
bis auf das die ablenkung weg das ist
eine ablenkung von gott statt eine
ablenkung von den platonischen formen
aber ethisch gesehen ist die folge genau
deshalb also noch wollte ich ein haufen
von vilshofen
es sprechen einzelne philosophinnen aber
das war sozusagen die erste hälfte der
vorlesung weil wir bisher eigentlich
keine einzelne vieles offen besprochen
haben sondern männer die über frauen
gesprochen haben und im allgemein was
möglich war für frauen in der in der
spätantike
also ich dachte ich würde ich hier jetzt
pause macht und sehen ob jemand fragen
hat also einen brief von marc keller an
portfolios
nein das hätte hätte ich erwähnt
es wäre schon schön gewesen dass also
wirken außer ich haben bisher überhaupt
keine texte gesprochen die von frauen
geschrieben würden werde ich auch nichts
ich weiß was ich jetzt besprechen werde
sind texte wo frauen sozusagen im
mittelpunkt stehen und sich äußern
irgendwie aber die texte selbst sind
immer von männern geschrieben
das ist also eine grundregel ist
natürlich verschieden haben also sehr
sehr viel einfluss hat die platonische
terry und dort ist die tugend und das
betonen es gibt eine tugend für jedes
für jeden zellen teil zb moderat seien
zur vorsicht ist die tugend der begierde
und die gerechtigkeit live plattform
innerhalb des individuums ist das
altenteil zusammenarbeiten wie sie sein
soll nämlich die untere teile pärchen
auf vernunft und vernunft regiert also
wenn vernunft regiert und die unsere
seelen zeile sich regieren lässt dass es
gerechtigkeit und englischer weise in
dem start ist gerechtigkeit dass die
philosophen regieren und die anderen
blick jetzt werden aber die historiker
gründen zum beispiel sagen vernünftig
sein ist die tugend die die kapazität
oder die fähigkeit zur vernunft haben
sondern direkt die wahrheit zu begreifen
und das einzusetzen dass es die zum
beispiel also eigentlich zu wissen was
zu tun ist das zu tun also sehr
intellektuell esstisch aires dort ließ
ist definiert die tugend als eine
neigung die mitte zwischen zwei extremen
zu wählen
also es verschieden habe ich würde sagen
eigentlich immer ist das sehr stark mit
vernunft verbunden also vernünftig in
der antike heißt thüringen seien fast
immer vernünftig sein und erfolgreich
die vernunft einzusetzen und das ist wie
ich habe versucht so argumentieren das
ist wirklich ein grund oder ja das ist
vielleicht ein stoß für die flow sowie
in richtung frauen ernst zu nehmen weil
so lang man frauen freuen man zugibt
dass frauen vernünftig sind also die
eine förderfähigkeit und wenn man noch
dazu sagt ja und jugendlich sein ist
nicht mehr und nicht weniger als
erfolgreich die förderung zu benutzen
dann müsste man wirklich erklären warum
frauen nicht zugänglich sein könnten und
dass man die meiste sehen dass das es
daraus folgt dass sie doch die türken
besitzen können oder andere fragen
ja das war die türen der höflichkeit auf
lichkeit rechtsphilosophie und was
übrigens hier schön heißt im gegensatz
zu was wir zu dem was wir letzte woche
oder vor zwei wochen gesehen haben ist
dass die figuren die ich jetzt
besprechen werde
die waren alle echt also es gab wirklich
diese frauen wie gesagt ich werde leider
keinen text beschreiben oder
zusammenpassen können der von einer frau
geschrieben wurde
stattdessen haben wir texte die von
männern geschrieben würden wo in diesem
fall authentische echte frauen
beschreiben und die frage ist deswegen
jetzt nicht existierten sie überhaupt
wie bei den kategorien rennen hat dass
irgendwas mit einer echten frau zu tun
haben uns immer gefragt oder diotima
hier ist die frage wie nah ist diese
beschreibung an die erste frau und die
natürlich ist die antwort normalerweise
wissen wir nicht also ist immer noch wir
sind immer noch sehr und in unsicherheit
und das könnte ich jetzt werde ich
vielleicht noch mal am ende des
semesters sagen aber werde ich so ein
jetzt im voraus mit vorsicht sagen ich
habe jetzt sozusagen eine hypothese dass
die geschichte der frauen in flüsse wie
in vier etappen sich entwickelt nämlich
antike also klassische antike und das
geld wie sie sein werden das gilt auch
für indien wo wir schon frauen dabei
haben aber überhaupt nicht wissen können
ob die frauen erst sind dann haben wir
nächste etappe erste frauen vielleicht
nicht authentische ideen also ideen
werden echten frauen zugeschrieben also
wir können sagen es gab die
denn das und jene philosophen aber wir
wissen nicht und bedenkt was sie gesagt
hat
nächste etappe mit die geschichte texte
die wirklich von frauen verfasst wurden
zum beispiel hätte galt hier ist dass
man könnte denken okay jetzt haben wir
unser ziel erreicht aber diese texte
sind nur kontrovers philosophisch vierte
etappe frühe moderne oder schwellen zeit
dann haben wir texte die wirklich von
wirklich von wirklichen frauen
geschrieben würden die wirklich
unumstritten philosophisch sind also um
umstritten dass die texte von frauen
geschrieben würden dass die frau
entwicklungsziele haben und dass die
zwar dass die texte philosophisch sind
also mark cavendish oder solche solche
leute also das sind sie zusammen voll
dabei auf augenhöhe mit männern zum
ersten mal und das habe ich glaube ich
in der ersten sitzung gesagt dass man
das so man nie unterschätzen
diese unterschiede von etappe zu etappe
auf jeden fall was haben wir dann für
philosophie
also erstens war wollte ich zwei
philosophinnen beschreiben die in so
einem vierten jahrhundert vor christus
gelebt haben dass das ein fehler wie
würden sie auf dem herd hat das sollte
vierte jahrhundert vor christus nach
nicht nach christus und philosophinnen
in der spätantike schon ein bisschen
interessant ist adt adt heißt sie war
eine schlüsselfigur bei den köthenern
einem nicht sehr bekannte philosophische
bewegung die hedonistisch weise was sie
sind vor allem dafür bekannt dass die
hedonistischen und wenn er mal mit den
apple kennern verglichen
und zwar in folgender weise apple kurs
und seine kumpels ist eine nachfolge
haben gelehrt dass lust das wichtigste
ist also hayden ist ja jetzt also preise
auf englisch lust ist das beste im leben
und zweck des lebens sogar deswegen sind
sie hedonisten aber ist man muss
vernünftig lust nach gehen damit man
lust über über das ganze leben
maximieren kann zum beispiel muss man
sehr oft ein lust jetzt dann
überspringen oder vermeiden weil man
weiß über die längere zeit da habe ich
mehr lust wenn ich das nicht jetzt
sofort nehme paradebeispiel ist soll
jetzt nichts besoffen werden weil ich
morgen kopfweh haben werde
ok oder ist soll nichts tun würde wovon
ich krankheiten entwickeln könnte
beispiel von epikur ich soll nicht sex
haben weil ich könnte dann kennen da
kriegen oder die frau konnte kinder
kriegen und das bringt unmenge schmerz
war es so ärgerlich ist anscheinend
kennt es war die kirche im gegensatz
dazu werden dass sie sind dafür unter
antike philosophie vorschüssen sie dafür
bekannt dass sie anscheinend die einzige
antike philosophen waren die keine
interesse hatten an heute also glücklich
kite über das ganze leben sie wollten
nur glücklich kite jetzt haben jetzt
hier jetzt lust jetzt bitte jetzt das
ist ihre theorie also bürger und es gibt
viele anekdoten über den begründer diese
bewegung alles typos und diese diese es
gibt alles
und anekdoten über ihn und die sind
wirklich sehr lustig die haben alle
damit zu tun dass er immer wusste dann
genommen hat jedes mal dass er konnte
und die lustige sachen die er darüber
gesagt hat zum beispiel war immer unter
reichen männern und könne ihn weil er
wusste sie hatten das geld und die
könnten ihm dann mehr lust geben oder
vorbereiten
und einmal hat es natürlich ist das nur
eine legende aber angeblich hat er in
zenica die organist getroffen und das
war gerade dabei so karotten oder
wurzelgemüse es zu waschen damit er sie
essen konnte und die organisation des
depots wenn du lernen würdest gemüse
zuerst ein würdest du nicht immer zum
könig gehen müssen um in als depressiv
wenn du bereit wäre es zum könig zu
gehen würdest du nicht immer gemüse
essen müssen
oder man sieht ihnen wo er hinein kopf
rein geht es pro fest richtig gewollt
oder und wie man teilt ihnen dafür wenn
er sagt das problem ist nicht einzugehen
sondern nicht wieder herauskommen zu
können
also viele viele geschichten über ihn
diese eben diese die richtung
er ist ich würde sagen er ist irgendwie
so 1 1 gegen die orgel ist also eher
sein georgen ist der immer diese lustige
sachen sagt wie sie wissen werden sie
bald werde gleich etwas darüber sagen
also es gibt alte lustige anekdoten
gewinnen aber er ist nicht dafür dass
man erst sich einschränkt und die lust
sie kontrolliert erst dafür dass man so
viel lust empfindet wie möglich aber er
war eigentlich eher hat das anscheinend
nicht so thematisiert das kam mit einem
anderen als topos der erste post der
jüngere und dieses typus der junge hat
dann eine technologie entwickelt wo
alles also die idee ist alle unser
wissen und begreifen der welt geht immer
darum dass wir jetzt hier und jetzt eine
verbindung mit irgendeiner irgendeiner
aspekt der häuslichen weil es dann also
die idee ist dass wir immer in dem
moment von dem objekt beeinflusst werden
zum beispiel hat er gesagt wenn sie da
sehen dann werden sie beweist und die
idee jetzt anscheinend dass er eine
person energie entwickelt hat um diese
art hedonismus zu erklären
interessante für uns ist dass dieser
junge des zirkus dass er ned so
didaktisch hier ist das heißt von der
mutter gelehrt dass und seine mutter war
hrt
sie ist die tochter des älteren als
typus und die mutter des jungen
also waren drei generationen sie es die
binde figur mit den für die für die drei
kennen er
leider wissen wir nicht sehr viel über
sie aber sie hat anscheinend die
philosophische ansichten des zionismus
an den jungen alters depots vermittelt
und deswegen hat die schule ist
sozusagen ermöglicht das ist schon
interessant
wichtiger als figuren ist hier parken
und über sie haben sie vielleicht sogar
gehört sie war mit einem chemiker namens
gratis verheiratet und es gibt
geschichten über dieses ehepaar die zum
teil sehr lustig sind um das erkennt man
sich kurz ein bisschen über tennis muss
sagen wie sie wahrscheinlich wissen
geht's ismus zynismus zenica heißt so
etwas wie hund oder hund für das oft
anders heißt hund das sind das heißt die
philosophen die hunde gelebt haben oder
vielleicht die philosophen die die hunde
andere leute an gewählt haben weil sie
immer andere leute kritisiert haben oder
vielleicht heißen sie kritiker weil sie
weit in den und gymnasium zusammen waren
das ist aber ein bisschen langweilig
also ich bevorzuge die erste zwei
erklärungen und der russischen liga ist
natürlich die organist die aktie fiel
von ihm wissen wir wägen einen anderen
tagen ist viel später die organismus der
eine hauptquelle es frei diese anekdoten
und es gibt hunderte anekdoten über die
open ist ein bisschen wie oskar wild
oder goethe also wenn wenn jemand ein
cleveres spruch aus denkt sagt man
nichts sie hat das erfunden sondern
diogenes hat mal gesagt dass ich konnte
wahrscheinlich die restliche zeit damit
verbringen nur dadurch dass ich sie
anekdoten
sie werde stattdessen nur mein lieblings
eine tote dort jetzt ein
dies ist im haus eines reichen mannes
und das alles super super schön marmor
gold- silber- und der mann steht da ganz
stolz
und dann trägt sie ordentlich ist zehn
mann und spuckt in seinem gesicht und
der reiche mann soll ja was war das und
jürgen ist sagt tut mir leid aber müsste
spotten und sonst ist hier alles so
schön
ok
die grundlegende idee des zionismus ist
natürlich zu leben wie ein hund zum
beispiel hat junges anscheinend versucht
rohes fleisch zu essen weil es nicht
natürlich ist gleich zu kochen oder
sowas und bekanntlich hat er im offenen
gelebt in ein gefäß und so weiter und so
fort die die tatsache dass er seine
körperliche bedürfnisse immer befriedigt
hat ganz natürlich spielt auch eine
rolle in dieser in diesen toten zum
beispiel war einmal am marktplatz und
hat in der öffentlichkeit gegessen was
damals nichts in das jetzt sieht man
dass überall aber damals war das ein
bisschen unangemessen und jemand hat ihn
gefragt warum er das tut und warum isst
du am marktplatz und dann aber gesagt
wie hungrig geworden denn ein anderes
mal hat er sich in der öffentlichkeit
befriedigt und würde dafür dass sie was
ich meine jacke und hut würde dafür
kritisiert und er hat gesagt ich wünsche
ihm den wunsch ihn nur dass ich mein
hunger lösen könnte so leicht dadurch
dass ich einfach hier rein
ok sie haben den eindruck jetzt dann
haben wir jetzt müssen sie sich
vorstellen wir sind immer noch im
vierten jahrhundert vor christus dann
haben wir eine weibliche zynikerin wie
kann das ausschauen
diese frau hat sich in einem zyniker kts
ist ein nachfolger von dirk nies
verliebt und sie wollte ihn unbedingt
heiraten und sie hat sie hat bedroht
dass die salzburg begeht wenn sie nicht
erlaubt wird in zu heiraten und die
eltern sagen körpers und was werden wir
machen wir müssen gratis irgendwie
überzeugen dass er sie überzeugt ihn
nicht zu heiraten aber das wäre für sie
eine katastrophe sie seien ja ob meine
frau sie kann nicht mit diesen karten
umgehen
also ist sie sagen gratis es soll sie
einreden ihn zu vergessen
dann geht gratis im nimmt seine kleidung
aus und sagt du siehst ja ist alles was
ich habe und dann dann nimmt sie ihre
kleidung aus sagt ich kommentiere
und dann sind sie der verheiratete
chemiker haben sex in der öffentlichkeit
natürlich
und dann gibt es ein paar anekdoten über
sie bei diogenes lea thies also eine
anekdote sie würde von einem anderen
fürs of einen atheistischen philosoph
namens theodoros beleidigt und als rache
hat sie gesagt alles was tier doris mit
recht machen darf kann hierauf mit auch
mit rechts machen
der gast kann sich selbst schlagen mit
recht deswegen darf ich dich schlagen
hahaha und dann sagt er als wache ist er
zitiert ein theaterstück die bahai und
dieses hat ist das ist sie die die
frauenarbeit verlassen hat also die die
soeben auf deutsch
die dewb verlassen hat und dann sagt sie
dann sagt sie ist es besser wenn ich
meine zeit mit baby verbringen würde
statt mit pda also mit meldung es ist
sich anscheinend als philosophin
verteidigt an viel mehr wissen wir über
sie ist ja anscheinend auch werke
geschrieben wie national wieder verloren
sind
ok also man sieht hier dass diese wie
gesagt konto kulturelle bewegungen platz
gemacht haben für frauen
und vielleicht könnte man sogar sagen
dass das auch irgendwie jetzt die rolle
der frauen in christen später an dem
christentum dadurch gerechtfertigt dass
eine platonische für solche theorie
schon anwesen war womit dass man das
begründen konnte aber mal so auch nicht
vergessen dass in der spätantike vor
allem im zweiten drittel
also vor bis constantin wahl christentum
auch irgendwie eine art gegen
gesellschaftliche bewegung wie sehr
gegen die gesellschaft razzia die partie
ist die berühmteste weibliche antike
philosophen
sie lebte in alexandria und war in würde
von einer praktisch in einer
ausscheidung von christen umgebracht
wahrscheinlich aus politischen gründen
und dass es gibt eine fan übrigens dazu
über sie namens agora und der film ist
interessant da sag ich das glaube ich
sogar schon gesagt der verein ist
interessant weil das zeigt wie wie
gefährlich die christen waren aus sicht
der heimischen also die waren wirklich
die eigentlich weniger die wahren
absichtlich an asketisch und so weiter
also ist so soll eine eine kontinuität
zwischen den rheinischen kliniken und
die christliche philosophen in der
spätantike vom lebensstil eher
überraschende weise habe ich nicht sehr
viel über ihr partner zu sagen sie ist
nicht die einzige heimische philosophen
der spätantike aber wir wissen auch es
gab eine erste guinea von athen sie war
die tochter des erneuerers der
platonischen schule in athen einen
gewissen pluta nicht der berühmte pluta
ein weiterer pro tag also nicht der
historiker und sie hat angeblich diesen
philosoph den vorher erwähnt habe paulus
sie hat ihm angeblich theologie bei ihr
praktisches praktisch heidnische
religion
ob sie wirklich philosophin war es nicht
so klar die partie ist er bekannt und
berühmt weil sie von christen ermordet
wurde
und wenn normalerweise wenn man sich
fragt wer ist wer ist das haupt beispiel
einer philosophen aus der antike razzia
sagen aber wir haben hier ein problem
nämlich dass wir so gut wie gar nichts
über jede philosophischen finde solche
ansichten dessen was wir wissen ist dass
die mathematikerin war und hier haben
wir sogar werke von ihr oder nicht werke
aber bruchstücke aus paar werke von ihr
zu mathematische themen zum beispiel
einen kommentar zum tolle meyers also
sie war wirklich eins der eine
ernsthafte mathematikerin hat
mathematische theoreme bewiesen usw
und viele gehen davon aus dass als
spätantike vieles so finden die
interesse an mathematik hat und sowieso
weil tourismus sehr stark in dieser zeit
war musste sie eine platonische rennt
gewesen sein was sehr naheliegend ist
aber wir wissen nichts über ihr die
platonische lehre eingenommen sie war
überhaupt eine platane karen ihr dass
sie überhaupt interesse einflüsse wie
hatten hatte kennen wir nur durch briefe
ihre schule senesie es ein bisschen
kritisch ob also sie als philosophen
oder und schweige davon als haupt
philosoph in der spätantike zu
beschreiben wäre wirklich sehr sehr
übertrieben
also habe ich gesagt habe ich nicht sehr
viel über sie zu sagen weil sie als
philosophen eigentlich nichts in den
belegen die wir haben eigentlich nicht
auftaucht zum glück gibt dass diese
christliche geborenen und da wollte ich
zwei vor allem in einem
nämlich marina sie ist 1 379 gestorben
und monika in 387 gestorben also fast
gleichzeitig macchina ist wie gesagt die
schwester von den griechischen
kirchenvätern greger von nizza und basel
der große oder beißen von kaiser her und
monika ist die mutter des augustinus
wenn sie die bekannteste gelesen haben
dann wissen sie was über monika sie war
hat eine sehr große rolle gespielt in
erleben augustinus war mitverantwortlich
dass er über christ geworden ist und war
auch dabei als er ist einen großen
schritt in richtung christentum in
philosophie gemacht hat ein text was ich
in dem haben
nachdem auf der website verfügbar
gemacht habe ist ein auszug aus der
bekenntnisse über sie ich wollte jetzt
einen ein kleines paragraf über sie
lesen das kommt von einer berühmten
szene aus der bekenntnisse des
augustinus haben wo sie bei den
geladenen sind und die treffen also ich
sehe es mit er es mit seiner mutter
monica und sie kommen in praktischen
philosophisch gespräch miteinander und
dann sagt er
als unsere unterhaltung sowie im
ergebnis kann fleischliche genüsse wie
groß sie sein und welchen körperlichen
glanz auch immer sie erstrahlten
deuteten mit der freude jenes lebens
nicht nur kleinen vergleich sondern
seien nicht einmal der erwähnung wert
da richteten wir uns in noch klären dem
verlangen nach ihm auf unterwanderten
dabei alle körperliche stunden stufen
auch den himmel von dem aus sonne mond
und sterne die erde beleuchten und noch
höher stiegen wir in stillem nachdenken
im gespräch bei bewundern seiner werke
deiner gott okay
und wir kommen zu unseren geißeln und
übersteigen auch sie um die region nie
versagen überflusses hören wo du ist
real auf ewig wieder auf der wiese der
wahrheit das leben dort das ist die ist
das ist die weisheit durch die alle
diese dinge geworden sind auch alles was
war und was sein wird aber es wird
nichts sondern sie ist so wie sie war
und so wird sie immer sein
das ist ein praktisch aufsteigen in
richtung gott und sollte man es
wahrscheinlich an den symposien erinnern
das ist platonische steigerung von den
körperlichen zu den körperlichen zudem
immer immer bleibenden sachen hier gott
statt die formen
grund man könnte etwas sagen in dieser
szene spielt man gefasst die rolle einer
christlichen dia thema noch
interessanter ist die frau die ich die
christliche sache hieß wurde der
christliche ist sollte diesen nennen
würde aber weil ich nämlich macchina es
gibt eine sehr interessanten werk von
gregor von nizza namens über die zelle
und auferstehung und in diesem werk
beschreibt er eine szene wo er mit
marina sitzt oder sie ist sie liegt im
sterben
und er ist und seine schwester und
deswegen hier sehr sehr traurig und sie
erklärt ihn warum er nicht traurig sein
sollen
dadurch dass sie eine ganze theorie der
zelle entfaltet der ganze text ist
übrigens verfügbar auf der website wenn
sie das lesen aber auch englisch so weit
vielleicht gibt es eine deutsche
übersetzung aber weiß es nicht denkt
nicht
dieser text ist sehr interessant und
passt relativ gut zu den themen die wir
schon gesagt haben wir sehen haben zum
beispiel sagt sie dass die seele ein
intellektuelles substanz ist ein gott
ähnliches substanz und gibt wäre die
argumente warum der menschen nicht
einfach körperlich sein könnte zum
beispiel wie sie sagt wenn wir aus nur
aus körperlichen zutaten geschaffen
werden könnten könnte eine statue sich
selbst aus browns zusammenbauen
das ist genau so unvernünftig allerdings
ist eigentlich alles sehr platonisch
kurzum sie übrigens sie verteidigt auch
die auferstehung dadurch dass sie sagt
wenn wenn unsere seele jetzt kontrolle
über unseres durchhänger hat also die
elemente in unserem körper wenn die säle
in bereit ist diese elemente zu steuern
und kontrollieren dann solange sie
überlebt nach dem tod und sie hat all
diese platonische argumente dafür dann
kann sie immer wieder in der zukunft
wenn sie will
die zutaten wieder sammeln und wieder
einen körperteil ausbauen und das ist
die auferstehung oder beziehungsweise
gott kann das für uns tun und dann kann
die seele wieder in der imstande sein
das zu kontrollieren und das gegen die
heimische philosophen die das bestreiten
ist interessant dass sie all diese
platonische argumente nimmt um die
rebellen terry zu entwickeln
aber sie sagt ausdrücklich dass wir nur
die heimische philosophen folgen soll
wenn sie in einklang mit der bibel sind
und zb findet sie dass sie sie dass
diese drei säle nähe des platzes
problematisch ist weil wir wissen hat
der bibel dass manche leute wie mäuse
wie mäuse ohne begierde leben konnten
also die haben das völlig vernichtet so
sagen
und deswegen neigt sie mir einiges in
eines weiß ich also eine historische
richtung sein wert würde nämlich wir
sind sozusagen durch und durch
vernünftig also was wir hier haben dann
ist eine wahrscheinlich könnte man das
als christliches platonisch musste
schreiben
das heißt platonisch muss unter der
voraussetzung dass wir nur platten
soweit verfolgen dass wir innerhalb der
christlichen lehre bleiben
offensichtliche frage was hat das alles
mit marina zu tun
wir haben einen weiteren text über sie
auch von gregor von nizza oder einen
guten einen ergiebigen text über sie von
gregor von nizza und das ist ein leben
der krieger und das passt vielmehr zu
dieser diesem muster der hna geografie
die wunde die sie geschaffen hatte sich
selbst geheilt hat und blablabla es
überhaupt nicht sehr interessant aber
bis auf diese ästhetische züge tut man
sich schwer philosophische themen da
raus zu kriegen und dann muss man diesen
text grünste argumentiert wirklich visa
card ist meine software würde sowieso
eines offensichtlich susan eine
nachahmung des weitern also die die
frage ist natürlich ob marina selbst so
argumentiert hat oder konnte oder ob
gregor von nizza der natürlich ein sehr
praktischer philosophie
das kennen wir aus
an den werken ob er so sagen sie als
murphys hergenommen hat also als
praktisch sprachrohr genommen hat für
seine argumente und seine ideen oder
vielleicht eine mischung wie gesagt
meine antwort darauf ist eigentlich
wissen wir nicht aber ich würde
mindestens sagen
der text setzt voraus dass es mindestens
so seien dramatisch plausibel ist oder
denkbar ist dass marina so argumentiert
und ist nicht als ob er sagt und war das
erstaunlich war sie als frau da hat das
alles gemacht dass erwähnt sie überhaupt
erwähnt er überhaupt nichts
er nennt sie immer der lehrer und das
war es was ist denn sie ist der lehrer
von ihm und es ist mindestens deswegen
wie gesagt also erst mindestens eine
annahme des taxis dass sie das ist
sozusagen realistisch ist dass sie
philosophisch argumentieren sogar solche
argumentieren konnte übrigens monika
taucht nicht nur in der bekenntnisse auf
sondern in mehreren frühen dialogen von
des augustinus wo er mit seinen jungen
freundin die philosophin gespräch ist
und dann kommt man rein und macht oft
ein entscheidendes argument im
christentum zu verteidigen weil sie es
so sagen
die große helden und vertreterinnen des
christentums dieses leben also hier
würde ich sagen wir sind wirklich sehr
nah dran erzählt philosophinnen zu haben
die wirklich so seien überzeugend in den
philosophischen texten auftauchen und
meiner meinung nach von dem was ich
gesehen habe ist dieser text von brega
von nutzer wahrscheinlich die
interessanteste darstellung eines
philosophischen frau einer
philosophischen fragen der in der
gänzlichen antike in der wissens in der
europäischen antike
der text sehr wenig gelesen weil zum
teil weil niemand christliche autor
ernst nimmt alles philosophen also
geigerin von ics man gut dass sich ziel
ist des heute des teufels arbeitskreis
schlecht also christen spielen fast
keine rolle in unserer geschichte der
antiken philosophie
das sollen sie aber und das ist ein
beispiel dafür
weil da haben wir das beste beispiel
dafür dass eine philosophie in der
antike das beste beispiel ist nicht sehr
partiell das beste beispiel ist marina
okay
sie ist nur sehr kurz als schlusswort
wickeln wir das alles mit den themen
vergleichen die wir in den letzten zwei
wochen gesehen haben wie anders ist das
und so weiter also was ich sagen würde
ist das also irgendwie natürlich ist das
viel weiter entwickelt als diese idee
frauen können nur so haushalts theorie
dann letztlich neuhaus als theorie
äußern
allerdings ist es auffällig dass selbst
also all diese texte die häuslesbauer
nabel der brief an marc keller
diese keine toten über chemische frauen
also vivaki und sogar diese werk über
seele und marine immer im mittelpunkt
ist serie gegen körper immer immer dass
immer der punkt also diese weibliche
philosophen die sind da um uns also uns
männer wahrscheinlich weg von dem körper
sie für einrichtung seele und das ist
irgendwie ist man könnte fast vermuten
dass ironisch gemeint also das benehmen
eine frau alle denken frauen sind
diejenigen die am meisten von den körper
beherrscht werden
deswegen nehmen wir eine frau als
sprachrohr für diese idee dass wir doch
nicht sklaven des körpers sein sollte
den körper entkommen natürlich ist das
sowieso eine sehr sehr allgemeines thema
im spätantiken philosophie gibt es viele
texte wo männer das auch sagen aber ist
meiner meinung nach kein zufall dass
sozusagen die neue fassung der frauen
fühlen sich also die frage fluss wie war
haushalt jetzt ist serie über corp
körper das ist sozusagen frauen flüssig
innerhalb des platzes muss aber manchmal
finden wir solche texte die nahe tragen
kommen wirklich endlich zugeben dass
eine frau einfach eine philosophen sein
kann und das ist sowieso eine sehr
grundlegende lehre innerhalb latin es
muss sehr über körper und das marina
mindestens dieser sprachrohr dafür ist
und vielleicht sogar dasselbe dafür
argumentiert hat das zeigt uns dass
frauen jetzt wirklich dabei sind bei den
hauptthemen der philosophie vielleicht
nicht logisch oder andere sachen also
sehr beschränkt thematisch aber immerhin
haben wir fortschritt gemacht seit der
früh antike nächste woche bleiben wir in
der klassen antike aber in indien und
dann machen wir sind dann kommt
mittelalter aber hat jemand fragen
[Musik]
was meinen sie was ich gelesen habe dass
im neuen buch neuen § 24 aber das ist in
dem text ist der hat der website heißt
auf deutsch dass jetzt endlich ein
deutscher text okay gut also wir sehen
uns nächste woche präsentieren